to this strategy and resources committee
meeting on the 23rd of November
2023 my name is councelor Mark darham
and I'm the chairperson of this
committee members we are streaming this
meeting as well as recording hopefully
and by being present in this meeting you
are giving your consent to being
recorded during each item put up your
hand to indicate if you wish to speak
and I will then invite you at the
appropriate time members please avoid
approaching the top table as this could
create interference with the cameras and
live stream please note that the live
stream YouTube live stream sound
recording is dependent on the correct
use of microphones therefore can I ask
when invited to speak you remember to
turn on your microphone and turn it off
when finished please reference a page or
paragraph number when referring to the
agenda papers and keep your
contributions as clear and concise as
possible and I'm going to be extremely
strict on that and you're not going to
get multiple opportunities to talk
apologies for absence may have apologies
for absence please
Clark yes chairman thank you apologies
been received from councel Jennings and
councel spencley Nick spencley is
attending as subtitute for all Council
JS thank you thank you very much indeed
item three minutes it's recommended that
the minutes of the meeting held on the
9th of November found on pages 5 to 10
are approved us a true and accurate
record councelor
fluka thank you chairman and I I just by
start by saying I I never think it's a
good idea to put a stopwatch on
Democracy regardless coun fluka can I
what is your question about the minutes
please chairman
accuracy please then what is your point
of accuracy um so if we look at uh the
resolution on page
five um chairman
I I would have thought these minutes
have been read by somebody but um
Prosperity chairman I I when say councel
fluk comments been recorded for
Prosperity um I don't think there's
anything prosperous about anything we're
going to look at tonight I can only
think that that was poity or perpetuity
chairman but it's clearly not the right
word in there and it's certainly not one
that I would have used in that context
well Council fluka that's clearly a
typon will be amended accordingly have
you any others well only say chairman if
you picked up on that yourself we would
have moved on no absolutely that's fine
point taken thank you um so if they
unless there are any other comments do I
have a oh I so move do I have a second
for those thank you councelor Sidle
those in favor please
show thank you very much indeed item
four is Declarations of interest to
disclose the existence and nature of
anyos disclosable pecuniary interests
other registerable interests and non-reg
interests related to items of business
on the agenda having regard to paragraph
9 and appendix B of the code of conduct
for members me members you are reminded
that you are
also required to disclose any such
interests as soon as they become aware
should the need arise through the
meeting members any disclosures of
Interest nobody uh councelor fukat
chairman um just to confirm that I'm a
harbor commissioner thank you thank you
councilor fuka any others no thank you
very much indeed item five public
participation um I can advise that we
have one public speaker this evening uh
Mr
Sim um Mr Sim uh I take it you're in the
thank you
um we're making a space for
you if you'd like to take the warm seat
as it is now especially warmed for you
by councelor
lagen your members I've been advised
that we're not you you youtubing quite
yet but I propose to carry on um
Mr Sim in line with our protocol for
public
participation you have uh 2 minutes
which will be timed hopefully um and you
may address the
committee um but that will
um you the committee will not be able to
answer any questions as you're
aware so the timing will start when you
start to
speak thank you I'm David SM chair of
the M society and I wish to V like to
voice our views on item 10 uh fees and
charges schedule in particular the
increase in fees for TS barges more at
the high key over the years this
Authority has imposed charges on these
barges and in recent years has has
granted discounted Annual fees the fall
fee is apparently determined by the need
to recover the full cost of the Council
of maintaining the key we see this as
ignoring the contribution made by the
very presence of the temps barges in the
town which defines Bon as a maritime
town if you look at the front of your
agenda for tonight's meeting and every
other meeting of this Council there is
an image of a temp's barge and it
appears on the majority of published
brochures and reports by this Authority
the residents of the district are justly
proud of the existence of these historic
vessels they generate tourism they
generate income for business across the
district
they generate income for the council not
least in car parking fees the income
from car Parks is many thousands and
these charges are proposed to increase
by
7.4% fees for all moin for vessels other
than the temp barges is also proposed to
increase by
7.4% along with most other charges on
the schedule tonight however to more
ATMs barge will cost 72% more than 2223
nearly 10 times inflation
disproportionate and shortsighted The
Operators of the barges also need to
balance their books and the scale of
this fee does not reflect the
significant impact that these
magnificent vessels have upon the local
e econom economy the council ought to re
reconsider these fees and take a wider
view not just the need to recover
maintenance costs the wage fee for
operators of fully R Temps bares should
not be increased as detailed in appendix
a a lesser fee in live with inflation
only should be recommended to the next
four council
meeting extremely well timed and
practice no doubt Mr s thank you thank
you very much indeed your points are
your points are noted by members I'm
sure we now move to agenda item
six oh councelor spenley sorry forgive
me chair I should have declared uh an
entry in my register of interest I'm a
member of the TS bar selling trust thank
you that's noted so we and gender item
six Communications marketing and
engagement plan this is Mr
doors thank you chairman uh members uh
really good to be here this evening um a
lot has happened obviously since the
last uh plan uh came before members
um obviously covid which is is is still
with us at the moment um but a lot of
work's been done um I appreciate it was
quite a weighty document to uh to read
uh everything but the the plan basically
underpins the delivery of our corporate
plan 23 to
27 uh and supports a number of the key
Council strategies um and the Strategic
projects uh across the
authority the um small team that we have
uh are fairly well respected and known
within the community and uh wider
field uh our work being recognized uh
during covid by the local government
Association
uh for the um the community uh Co
Community guide that was produced and
some of the video production uh to um
highlight the uh the difficulties we
were all facing uh with covid and
encourage people to get out and exercise
safely uh and and probably more recently
the voter ID uh campaign that we
participate participated in um as I said
we're a small team part of the uh
strategy and resources directorate um
and within that team we have uh both
internal Communications and our digital
uh uh Communications and our tourism uh
specialist as
well as I said a lot of work's been done
uh since the last plan um the plan that
you have is is a very much a living
document um we like to be uh as um
Advanced as we can with the technologies
that we use so our social media
platforms over since the last plan came
we have Instagram we have Twitter uh we
are just about to embark on um a social
media platform called Next Door um which
provides um the ability will enable us
to communicate at a much more um micro
level with residents which could be
certainly quite advantageous for um uh
communicating waste uh issues but also
uh in times of
emergency I thought it might be useful
maybe uh just to give a couple of
highlight
of some of the work that is currently
that's been done and is is underway at
the moment um so the corporate website
um which is one of our key communication
tools uh is having somewhat of a fairly
extensive makeover uh with a um
Improvement group um from each of the
different areas of the council looking
at Page by Page looking at the wording
uh and trying to get that right in the
processes and the customer Journey uh so
there a lot of work on on on way with
that um you may have noticed is we've
deployed a new homepage which is clearer
and simpler and a lot easier uh for
residents to use um and some excellent
feedback and say from from the leader
and the counselor Stevens about the
Google search that we have on the
website so we're doing some work on that
at the moment to try and refine that
um and our site improve we have a system
we have software called site improve
which trolls the website uh is every
week and looks for broken links looks
for spelling mistakes um and looks at
accessibility looks at How are um search
endine optimization features uh and our
figures are up in the 90 98
97% uh so it's pretty good for an
authority uh of our size um you can't
really get that much better um where
links do break I should just point out
probably it's useful to know for members
where links often brute do break it's
where an an organization has moved the
link on their website so for example the
the um electoral commission moved a link
to their your right to vote and it broke
the link on our website but this
software enables us and we we check it
almost every day uh enables us to see
where the links are broken so we can
sort that out fairly quickly um another
side of the work uh of the team is our
film and TV work um uh as a chair will
know that uh the uh Essex film office uh
has been in operation for a little while
we were really pleased to have been
asked by the ethics film office to work
with them to help set it up uh and it's
gr Great Guns which is which is
fantastic to see um the film and TV work
is is is an interesting one for the
authority um most of the requests we get
and we do get a few come from uh
producers location Scouts um uh and
sometimes the the actual creators
themselves but they um a lot of a lot of
the occasions they're on asking for
advice and places to um to there might
be to film and they aren't Council land
um I think the exception we've had was
obviously the exx serpent where they
hire the prom par from from us um uh for
10 days probably the biggest unit
location unit we've had in the district
um but it's very important to us I mean
that generated a little bit of income
for us but um the sort of screen tourism
side of things uh is really important
people do come to the district to see
where certain things were filmed uh the
liar liar at tosur the ITV series um I
think pretty much saved some of the
coffee shops there because it was uh uh
had they not have um filmed um they
wouldn't have come but we've had some
big names here as well so um uh Tom hon
obviously with ESS serpent CLA Danes uh
Colin fur was here filming the mercy so
it you know we're putting the district
on the map um and I think that it's
great the E film office uh are now there
and we work very closely with creative
England as well there's been a little
bit of a hiccup we obviously with the
strikes with the acting World um but uh
I do do know that there is a location
scout who is looking uh in the district
at the moment so uh uh I can't say any
more than that because I generally don't
know very much more than that but uh
obviously we'll do when we
know uh I mentioned earlier about our
digital so our um our social media
presence again in the time that this
plan first came to members um has been
really important to us through covid it
was a pretty much a Lifeline to get
those messages out both the ones from
the government and from ourselves as an
authority
um we are very um Keen to challenge
misconceptions where where they're put
out on social media um and we do uh and
some of the comments which are sometimes
quite unsavory um we will we will go
back um we have a li limited ability um
with a couple of the biggest sites
because the admin will not allow the
council to be on those sites but uh we
do have his email address address and we
do correspond with them quite regularly
to say can you please change that and
they're pretty responsive
um and I think a great example uh more
recently uh was a little bit of an issue
with the local business and I think
councelor lagen uh did an absolutely
fine job of uh trying to dispel the
myths should we say on that one we're
we're using video using using videos a
lot more for our um video content uh
through Instagram uh and on the uh the
traditional social media sites um we're
exploring the use of possibly using
podcasts as a way of getting our
messages across um and probably this
only has really come about in recent
days uh as a a webinar that a colleague
went on was about the use of AI um I
think it's a question of either be in it
or be left behind so we we're keen to be
as I said quite Forward Thinking and and
look at how we can develop our use of
that um and then just most finally was
our our tourism um part of the team um
we have developed an amazingly
successful tourism partnership with the
t23 group uh chaired by uh James Burl
cook from the um uh um the Queen
Victoria in spittle Road and you will
sure know the walking Festival that was
held um in
September uh their first event um as a
as a partnership as a group phenomenal
ly successful um we're hoping that we
will be able to do it next year as well
um we met on Tuesday night with some
ideas of things that we could do um uh
and go bigger and better um so that's
quite encouraging and with the um the
volume and value report which is a
statistical analysis um which um will
tell us uh how our tourism industry has
been fairing uh the report is just about
to come out out so I think we can we'll
send that round to members at the end of
uh end of the month but we're hoping
that that will start to show a a
recovery from from where we've been in
the last few years um and I'm sure
chairman you you you'll know more than
anyone um how important that is um we're
also looking at a uh with with the
partnership a district guide uh which
will be placed in all of the the
accommodation uh in the rooms in the
accommodation in the district promoting
the district it be one of these hardback
magazines that uh we hope people don't
lift and take away with them but it's uh
um again another opportunity for us to
shout about the district and more
recently we've been advertising as as
we're you know encouraging uh visitors
back now uh in some of the really key
big National magazines like in Britain
magazine coast and Countryside magazine
so we're running campaigns to generate
and and that has through this last
summer has proven quite uh quite useful
particularly with The Walking Festival
um as I mentioned earlier you know we
are involved in quite a lot of um uh
projects across the authority um which
as I said tie all in with our corporate
plan um and um we're looking you know
we're never never wanting to stand still
so we're looking at doing a little bit
more with our social media um we'd like
to do some more um some more newsletters
we have some software that enables us we
do a business one and a client action
used letter at the moment which again
are quite popular um the members
bulletin uh and the parish bulletin
that's using the same software um but
we're always looking at new
opportunities as I say so
um yeah I think chairman I I'll leave it
there and just seek questions if there
are any thank you very much thank you Mr
doors um on the basis that you mentioned
tourism I perhaps have another
registerable interest as chairman of
visit
so it's for the record um it was
interesting you mentioned the film
office I mean the film office is a new
initiative from the Cy Council um and in
fact between January and June it bought
£500,000 into the county unfortunately
which fell away after June because of
the American Writers and actors strike
which was settled last week and the fans
have already started to ring it's rather
unfortunate that the owner of OC didn't
play ball because we had a project that
we were negotiating with him that would
have bought him several hundred th000 as
you well know but he just didn't want to
didn't want to engage but um yeah that's
very good so members we are being asked
to approve this but uh we have councelor
driver
indicating uh just two points one uh
just a point of accuracy you mentioned
about James Burl cook on page 12 3.5
he's referred to he is now a counselor
so since he refers to others as
counselors it might be just worthy to
note he is a counselor now yeah um and
on page
20 um which is I think appendix part of
appendix a it's just in relation to sort
of communication strategy and I noticed
that one of the bullet points that sits
here under
principles uh which is about three
bullet points up from
point4 on uh on page
20 uh digital first approach is a
priority I would question that I am I am
concerned that actually everything is
digital or the danger is and there is a
whole section of our community which are
sidelined as a consequence of that so
might I suggest something along the
lines of effective communication first
and then you could put digital when
social and electronic channels are the
most effective it just broadens it
otherwise actually there's a large
section of our community that are
excluded I think the point is probably
taken Mr do absolutely um I compliment
you on your disguise in appendix a on
page 26 that's very well done I would
never have guessed that was you
counselor stamp thank
you thank you oh I flashing then yeah
it's um yeah thank you for the report um
I'm glad you mentioned AI um because I
spoke to a director today about possibly
changing or making this communication
engagement plan flexible because it will
if every members I'm sure have read it
it says it comes back every four years
things will change within that four
years and I was assured because I was
going to put an amendment to this but I
have been assured that this come will
come back to this committee
as and when changes areed so effective
not affected thank you chair and also
one more thing um yet again um the walks
and everything is all molden Centric
this is a district don't have to keep
saying we have Burnham South mitchler
Bradwell haybridge can we start and
pearly wherever can we start to actually
look at treating us as a district and
not a modern Centric because we have got
the prom thank you chair thank you very
much members um yes Council fer chairman
um chairman there's there's something I
don't understand on page 27 under the
weaknesses I suspect it's only a typo um
but chairman I just really wanted to go
to um an appendix a on page 20 um
perhaps Mr dors could just confirm um it
says here all Council projects have a
Communications workstream identified to
receive communication support and
resources at Inception um I wonder if Mr
dors could just expand on that for my
benefit thank
you yeah certainly thank you um so uh
I'll just pick up councilor stamp's
point so the walking Festival uh and the
discussions that we had on Tuesday night
very very much are looking at the hold
of the district uh in fact the deputy
mayor Fiona CLE was was present uh we
got some fantastic ideas so rest assured
um and in terms of councelor councelor
fuk your your question
uh so um a member of the team uh
normally attends or is invited to attend
pretty much any project that is um uh we
don't sit on necessarily every single uh
meeting but we would be called in um uh
or ask for our advice or whatever might
be needed uh for some of the corporate
projects briefly I just wanted to pick
up on that because the the high key
regeneration project we we clearly uh
missed some of the stakeholders earlier
on in that and we subsequently had a uh
meeting with them um to give them you
know an indication of what was going on
so when I read that I was interested to
know how we didn't pick up on that so
maybe that's something we'll bear in
mind in the future because that is quite
an important work
stream right members we're being asked
to approve those in favor please
show thank you very much
indeed thank you Mr doors thank you
chair okay members we now agenda item
seven supplimentary estimates vment
procurement exemptions use of reserves
quarter
2 uh hello yes you're
on thank you chair um I think the report
is reasonably self-explanatory um but
just for members to note that there was
no viment or supplementary estimates
requested during the the period in
question which is um quarter 2 from 1st
of July to 30th of
September um there are four procurement
exemptions which were agreed and are
detailed at paragraph 3.5.1 for noting
and there was one draw down from
reserves which was agreed under
delegated authority During the period
which is detailed at paragraph
3.6.1 um and that was £20,000 to cover
the asset management software and
training um if members have got any
questions I'm happy to try and answer
thank you m this is just written noting
any any question councilor
focer I just really want to understand
what this Nexus ratable Value Finder
service refers to whether or not it
really does provide value at £10,000
chairman I'm sure you'll be aware of the
recent appeal decision at M Road
Bradwell or southminster Road Bradwell
um chairman where um it transpires that
someone had been living in a building
for 5 years and we'd been collecting
their waste and uh and the inspector the
planning inspector said yes this is a
separate dwelling and yes you can have
planning permission um two questions
really chairman it are we going to try
and recover those rates for four years
and bear in mind they were on the
domestic uh waste collection route why
nobody ever picked up that somebody was
living there and they weren't paying
rates well councilor fleo that is not
for this committee but I think will I
think perhaps Mrs Green are you able to
answer exactly what this service
is uh thank you chairman we are in the
process of responding fully to Mr flu uh
to councelor fluka because we need to be
clear the facts of the circumstances
which may not perhaps be as first appear
yeah I'm grateful chairman but there is
a planning inspector involved so I agree
with Mrs Green okay it sounds like it's
in hand councelor fluka so members we're
being asked to note those all in
agreement please show thank you very
much
indeed uh agenda item eight budgetary
control as at 30th of September
2023 again thank you chair so the
purpose of the report is to provide this
committee with information in relation
in relation to the financial performance
over the period 1st of April 2023 to
30th of September
2023 um at section four of the report um
the you will be able to note the revenue
budget position for the council as at
the end of that period and table one
provides an overview of the current um
forecast budget variances for the
council um just to point out that um at
table two there's a Reconciliation of
the original budget that was agreed to
the revised budget and at table three
there is um detail of all the um main
expenditure um areas of variance across
the council and likewise at table four
the the income
variances uh members may like like to
note that there is a separate appendix
appendix one which details the refuges
and recy cycling variances in more
detail um because of the um sort of
complexity and and the detail um that
sits behind
that at um section five of the report we
detail the um position in terms of the
salaries um for the council um and at
section seven we note the impact on the
um the projected impact on the general
fund balance for the
council um so just to give a very high
level overview um the position as
reported at table one is that we are
reporting um a forecast variance on our
employee costs of £97,000
overspend um and uh on non-employee cost
of a £33,000 under spend which gives um
a gross expenditure variance of £64,000
that is more than offset by an
overachievement on our income budgets of
35,000 so there is a net service
expenditure UND spend forecast of2
£41,000 as at the end of
September um in terms of the investment
income variance so the um additional
income we expect to receive on our
investments um that is shown at um
section seven in table six um and we are
forecasting a £500,000 um variance um
over achievement of income this year on
that so that gives rise overall to a
$742,000 projected budget over sorry
under spend for the council
so in terms of the impacts on the
general fund balance that then gives us
a projected general fund balance at the
close of the year of 5.8 million which
is um well above our um uh minimum level
of reserves of 2.6
million um at Section 8 we set out the
capital program for the financial year
and the current performance against that
um there are some planned um changes to
the capital program which are set out um
and the current status and explanation
of each individual line is detailed at
appendix
2 um I think they're the main highlights
of the report but if members have any
questions I'm happy to try and answer
thank
you it's certainly certainly a better
position than we had hoped members uh
councelor
driver thank you chair um on page uh 36
uh Table Three it's under
4.3.1 uh there are two lines line nine
in the table in line
13 where uh the budget and the forecast
at the end of
September well it's a very small uh
actual position given the size of the
budget and yet
online for both of those no variance is
expected and that just looks
odd to me there may be a very good
reason for it but they stand out to
me thank you Council driver um sometimes
there are timing differences in terms of
when we are kind of um invoiced for
expenditure so that the percentage may
look low at this point in the year even
though it is on track to um to spend by
the end of the year so um I will um take
that specific question away and look
into it just to make to give you
assurance that there um that that is
correct but it may well just be a timing
issue but they are just as it stands
here it does look odd I'll odd yeah
thank you Council
white thank you Mr yeah just following
on from that on um part nine um if
there's no budgetary issues on the parks
and Open Spaces why do we have the
cemeteries under PNC later on in the
agenda because surely if we're under
budget or on budget we shouldn't really
have the constraints that we've been led
to believe we have it's just something
that Council drivers sort of uh joged my
memory on really um I think there's a um
if I may come back there is um a wider
question around the service delivery of
that um of that service so um the the
report as we go into PNC we will discuss
the financial position of that but it's
not the only relevant consideration as
part of the report it's not all about
money councelor F yeah I do have a
question with to
5.1 um and 5.2 because what it's saying
is that a vacc back to 235,000
Bud which is not for
vac so in terms of we've already got an
over spend on staff cost
82,000 is does that include any position
of oversight um in terms of the um
vacancy Factor as well or is that
another amount to be
a thank you councilor ftic so yeah I set
out at table five the overall position
on employee cost is forecast to be
£97,000
overspend um and there's um the elements
that are set out within the table that
make that up so there is um an under
spend on Service delivery of £66,000 and
a projected overspend on strategy and
resources of 148 that does not include
the vacancy factor which is listed
separately in a separate line um in the
table below of £235,000 and the reason
the vacancy factor is shown separately
because it's not possible to attribute
at the start of year um which which
exact budget lines that will be achieved
against so it's shown as a kind of
corporate adjustment um and then there's
another factor which is the National
Insurance adjustment of £220,000 which
is also netted off to give the net
position of £97,000
but I understand that I'm just trying to
understand the statement with respect to
the 235,000
budgeted um FES fact that might not be
achieved and that doesn't appear
anywhere at the moment it's not been
achieved is it it's still assumed it
might be achieved I presume um
if I may time yeah so the vacancy factor
is essentially we're essentially showing
a an overspend um on our employee cost
of £82,000
um so that indicates that that vacancy
factor is not being achieved in this
Current financial year so that as I say
the the vacancy factor is shown
separately um just because it's not
possible to attribute that directly to
the individual service lines but you
you're correct that um the position as
reported currently is that we would not
be on track to deliver that vacancy
Factor saving this
year right thank you members uh you have
three recommendations little one
councilor
stamp thank you chair um I'd just like
to um say a few points I think they've
done very well on one waste and re waste
refug and recycling I think we should
actually say Well done to the council
for having 94k over then what they we
budgeted for um I also uh modern prom um
we lost at 35 underachieved 80k well
that was because it wasn't open enough
um I have a question though if you just
bear with me and I'll find it because I
have sort of question would be good
counselor Sam well hang up please I am I
am allowed to speak chair I have I'm
just ask we're waiting for a question
councelor Stan I've actually got things
where I've highlighted and I need to
actually look at what I'm highlighted
could could um could it be explained to
me what um
4.3.2 little to corporate the corporate
contingency of
172,000 is not expected to be required
uh expected to be required at this stage
can I have an explanation what that is
and is that in my terms like slush money
so is that going to stay in there is it
going well that's what it is does it
slush around do you know what I'm saying
yeah has it allocated or is it something
that we could use somewhere later down
the line it's quite serious question we
might be in financial difficulty in a PR
confidential thing okay thank you thank
you councilor stamp um yeah the
corporate contingency is is um the name
suggests a contingency budget which is
not allocated for a particular purpose
at the start of the year but is put
aside for any um unexpected um kind of
spend that we could have
anticipated
um however having said that yeah we're
not projecting to need it this financial
year and I think when we come on to the
mtfs papers later in the committee we
will consider actually whether it is
appropriate to keep that budget um in
place in future years so that is a
decision that may that councils may want
to take um thank you chair so it wasn't
a silly question even though it raised
some sniggers thank you no no no no no
it is coming up later in the agenda
though councel stamp councelor
Fluker um so the overachievement
forecast I presume that's investment
income so so in other words interest
interest received um 4.2 chairman I
wondered if uh the officer can confirm
um what our staff contributions are for
pensions um whether they're the the
statutary minimum of 8% which is 5% from
the employer and 3% from the employee um
look I should have started by paying
tribute to Mr porus because he certainly
writes a nice report but chairman on
table two 4.2 the
1.28 million budget for Revenue
commitments brought forward from 2223 I
sort of understand that but I was would
have thought that would have been 2122
so perhaps we can have a little bit of
information on that I think the Council
of stamps dealt with the Corp
172 um and chairman on um on
4.4.1 um chairman I noticed that we
always had this Legacy um hang hanging
around from the um the uh transformation
over the overestimation of car park
income um and I know this is a highly
controversial subject and and I'm sure
it's going to be even more when I say
what I'm going to say but we I noticed
that yet again we're offering free car
parking uh in the buildup to Christmas
and chairman you you'll remember from
some time ago when we did a lot of work
on this and it was established quite
clearly that there wasn't an awful lot
of churn in the car parts because most
of the parking spaces were taken up by
staff and local residents who knew they
were they were free um and I do Wonder
chairman when you look at the overall um
where we are financially whether or not
we can really afford these things and I
think that should be reviewed again um
next year or early in the year chairman
um because we need to close some of
these gaps um chairman number eight
building control chairman we've been
talking about this for donkey years we
are and I can you're notd in Way Reading
my mind but we really do need to to look
at building control chairman again
there's there you know we've got a
deficit there again um very few very few
local authorities offer this service uh
most of our major house builders will
use their own building control chairman
and I really do think that that looks
needs to be looked at and chairman on
page
38 um it's reported that the Council
Office lease income is expect to
overachieve this is at the bottom of
page 30
but chairman it was recently reported at
um at the one of the working groups that
we're actually when one takes the cost
of running the council offices uh versus
the income it seemed to me that there
was no profit and that's why I think
when we look at these things we
shouldn't do them in isolation chairman
and by just saying we're going to
achieve another 47,000 if we don't
understand our costs um chairman number
nine on page 39 I'd just like to ask the
officers why there is no variance on
lease of Mings income because everybody
else chairman on the river Crouch and
River Blackwater all the other operators
have actually increased um their moing
fees um I think chairman
uh if you just bear with me I think
we've dealt with the vacancy Factor but
I don't I think I'll pick up on that um
and and and 7.2 chairman on um page
40 um I it's a strange word to use the
uh property div dividends have called
you remember that I I did bring this up
the lamit fund I'm sure that the section
151 officer is monitoring it but I do
notice that a lot of Institutions are
now withdrawing their money from that
particular fund due to the fact it's not
um performing very well but chairman I
understand it is long-term but we it is
a long-term investment but it could take
five or 10 years to bounce back and I
know we don't have a lot of money in it
so chairman there's quite a lot of of uh
questions there but my final one is on
page
40 uh and this is where it mentions the
open general fund the opening general
fund balance and includes a draw down
from business Rate rates Equalization
Reserve um chairman there comes a time
when we really should be using these
reserves for for what they're really
meant for not popping up our wage costs
and run in this Council um I I also
noticed there's nothing in here about
the new hom bonus uh and I would have
expected that if we're withdrawing funds
from that Reserve I would have expected
it to be reported and I can only hope
that we're not actually using the new
homes bonus now to prop up the council's
funds but I suspect that's not the case
but the business rates Equalization
Reserve CH there's so many things that
this council could spend that on to
bring new businesses and I'm sure that
all members will be pleased that the new
uh industrial site at latchin has just
been um agreed just been approved and
that will bring in a huge amount of ndr
and I really do think it would be useful
to spend that in the south of the
district um to see if we can develop
employment I think we so chairman
there's a lot of questions there
chairman and I I I can see that all of
CRT are busily writing them down so I we
wouldn't want to disappoint you with the
answers councilor fluka but I I in in
you know I think it's important that we
knowe that of course this is this is the
position as at 30th of September and
You' so that effectively between April
and September so it's a small part of
the year and and and and councelor fuger
and I I I I can with you about the
Christmas parking and I don't recall
where that was agreed this year but um
I'm going to so I'm great I think
there's some bigger questions Lucas is
going to answer us I think there's
bigger questions in there chairman than
just the Christmas Park
fine okay thank you Council I'll try and
answer your questions in turn quickly um
okay so the the investment income that
you mentioned you're correct that so the
£500,000 that is um overachievement of
Interest against our investments this
financial year um the the question
around pension contributions at
4.2 um so you'll be aware that um as a
local Council we are a member of the
local government pensions scheme and as
such um the contributions that we pay
towards that are dictated centrally um
and at the moment that's 20.9% of um
salaries which we contribute into that
scheme and is outside of our Direct
Control um in terms of the commitments
for the last Financial year
I'm apologize but I'm not entirely clear
but um the commitments will have been
brought forward from 2223 which is the
previous Financial year so not 2122 so
I'm not quite sure if I um understood
you right there um in terms of the car
parking income Target you're right that
there's this kind of historical deficit
in that that that budget in terms of
income um and that is something we are
seeking to correct in the budget going
forward from next year um I might need
to take advice from my colleagues in
terms of the um decision or not around
the Christmas um parking um for this
year um in terms of building control I
didn't actually hear there was a
question in that so I think I'll just
take that as a
comment um in terms of lease income over
achieving um so we set a budget of what
we expected to achieve on our income in
terms of the council offices at the
start of the year and due to new tenants
coming in um we are now expecting to
overachieve which is why that's reported
in that way um as you'll be aware with
there's um fixed costs of running the
building so actually any new tenants
will make a contribution to the overall
running of of of the building they they
do not really incur much in the way of
additional costs to to host those um
tenants so that is why we're
overachieving on that
aspect um in terms of the lease and
income moing so again we set a budget at
the start of the year and we are on
track to achieve the income that we
forecast at the start of the year so I
think that was more of a
comment um on page 40 you mentioned
about property dividence calling um as
we discussed previously in relation to
the treasury management
strategy um yeah we have some funds held
in the the lit funds um and we um take
advice and um Direction into terms of um
what that property fund is achieving and
that's then reflected in our forecast
for the year and we have discussed that
previously um and finally in terms of um
the balances and the general fund
balance so the business rates
Equalization Reserve um was set up to
manage fluctuations in the council's
income um and essentially that that is
what it is being utilized for so when we
set the budget at the start of the year
we were not as confident about how much
business rates we were actually achieved
so the the forecast in the budget was
slightly lower having now had the year
end position we know that that did
overachieve and therefore it is
appropriate to then draw down on that
that um on that Reserve to then balance
the budget for this year and without the
use of that budget as you know we would
be in a deficit position for the council
overall for this year and that would
have to come out general fund balances
anyway so utilizing it for a different
purpose wouldn't actually achieve the
objective that I think this committee
agreed in July of setting a balanced
budget for the year um and you're
correct that new H home's bonus isn't
referenced um as you're aware that is
because new homes bonus is assumed in
the base budget for the year so there
isn't a specific reserve for new homes
bonus it is assumed to fund the overall
expenditure of the council thank you let
you come back once Council fluk yeah
chairman I will the first thing I'm
going to do is is congratulate the the
Chief Financial Officer for picking up
on all the questions I believe there was
a question about um building control and
that is why we we don't Outsource it so
if I didn't make it clear I did then and
perhaps someone can do a bit of work on
that chairman thank you thank you
councelor fluka councelor
Sidle thank you chair uh yeah in terms
of the uh free car parking that was a
decision that was made uh in conjunction
with myself and CLT uh and that's uh
what's happened on on previous years the
car parking is from 2:00 p.m. in the
afternoon it's not all day so that
prevents uh people just using using
those spaces and and yeah stopping the
the general chur the interesting thing
is uh we had a Communications meeting
this morning with Mr doors and one of
the things that been on social media has
been why aren't other local authorities
doing what molden does uh so it's
actually been a really positive uh
Factor about molden and about what we're
doing in terms of the runup to Christmas
that we do offer that free car car
parking we are looking at that next year
because one of the things that we want
want to do in future years is ensure
that ties in with the opening of the
market so we might actually change the
time um on on one of the Thursday so
that people come to the town and use the
market it's extreme you know beneficial
to to the town and to the businesses uh
in terms of building control the
actually the interesting thing about
that is other councils are looking to
use our services because they don't have
that so there is something that we will
be able to offer and uh use other
councils in the future so because we
have a building Control Function yeah
it's it's other councils are interested
in using that in their own councils so
that could be an extra Revenue stream
for the
organization good thank you councelor
white uh thank you U Mr chairman and
mine actually was on 7.3 under business
rates and er the budget uh for
2324 and the forecast it's 3% higher is
this taking into account the likely
additional um business rates in mland
and M SE and is this a finalized deal
that there's going to be um that the two
Villages lumped together to be a larger
Village or is this still open to
discussion thank
you um the S
you the um overall forecast um position
on the business rates as members will be
aware encompasses the entire District so
um it doesn't differentiate between
different um uh parishes within the
district and I don't think the other
question is pertinent to this committee
debate thank you if I might come back no
it's pertinent because a recent meeting
it was said that Ma was going to be a
larger Village and it would then lose
the um rural exemption for business rat
so the small business would have to pay
um the full rates and larger businesses
would lose their discounts bearing in
mind we don't really have various
facilities and you certainly don't pass
through ma it's not my ward but it it
does concern me although I don't I don't
have a business there
but um just come back quickly on that
point um I think the um we agreed to
come back with further detail didn't we
in terms of how the um makeup of the
individual um rural settlements which I
think is what you're referring to um is
determined for the purposes of the the
business rate relief um but as as we
said previously committee that is um
determined by planning and in terms of
the settlement numbers so it's not
something that's within um the direct
gift of members to control it we have to
set it in line with um agreed parameters
and we did um agree to bring that
information back just so you understand
that so we're still waiting for that
information um I believe so yeah okay
that's fine that's fine okay so members
uh as I said little one two little three
reviewing the
recommendations please
show
thank you very much that's a majority
anybody
against no okay okay councelor
white okay thank you very much
members okay we now move
to agenda item nine mtfs strategy or
mtfs update 2024 25 and 26 27 this LC
again thank you
chair um so the purposes of this report
is to present the revised medium-term
Financial strategy update for the years
2425 to
2627 um so for members awareness a
detailed review of budget has been
undertaken to identify changes that are
required um from the 2324 budget and
those are summarized at table one in the
report the summary shows the revised
position for this financial year along
with projections for the next three
years members will note that higher
expenditure is now budgeted for this
year which um has been agreed to be a
funded from approved draw downs from
reserves um including the 421k draw down
from the business rates Equalization
Reserve which we mentioned in the
previous report and was reported to
Council on the 13th of
July um so in terms of this year's
position that then prevents the general
fund Gap emerging for this year before
any um inye
variances uh members should note that
the table does not yet include the
impact of any savings proposals which
may be agreed or any proposed uplifts to
fees and charges which are set out in
the separate reports to this committee
to be considered
tonight so overall the table one shows
that um in for the next financial year
2425 before any other mitigating actions
we are projecting a budget gap of
$726,000 that rises to just over a
million in the second year of 2526 um
and to just over 1.25 million in
2627 um there is an improved um forecast
in terms of investment income due to the
ongoing higher interest rates um and in
particular there is an improved position
um in relation to the funding
assumptions and those were set out in
detail again at Council in on the 13th
of July
2023 so the changes to the mtfs
assumptions since the budget was set for
this year in February um are detailed at
paragraph 4.5 of the
report so if I just draw your attention
to section five of the report which sets
out the growth and unavoidable pressures
um members will see that um they are
listed um and total 163,000 in the next
financial year rising to
94,000 in the third year
in addition to those unavoidable
pressures um there are requests for
repairs and renewal expend Ren sorry
repairs and renewal um projects um and
they have been listed at the table at
section six um we have an ongoing budget
for repairs and renewals of um
£28,000 um and the items listed total £
134,000 so there is a £6,000 pressure on
that budget for next year
um I would like to draw members
particular attention to Section 8 the
areas of
uncertainty um the the figures presented
in this report tonight are very much um
best estimates at this point in time and
there are a number of areas where we
don't have complete complete Clarity yet
um including the pay award for next year
um the final level of council tax and
business rates that we could expect um
and the ongoing settlement um which is
not expected to be announced until late
December
so at section nine um I just show the
forecast general fund position um and as
I said in the previous report the
closing general fund balance projection
for this year is currently 5.8 million
um without any other measures to um
address the Gap position that will
reduce the general fund balance to 2.7
million by
2627 however um that is just about our
minimum um level of agreed
reserves so in conclusion um the medium
time the medium-term financial um plan
is an important component of the
council's strategic planning FL
framework particularly in the uncertain
economic climate that we face and key
financial decisions need to be set in
the context of that um this forward plan
enables us the opportunity to link our
um Financial Planning and our service
planning um and um we need to take a
longer term view um to ensure the
financial sustainability of the council
I'm happy to answer any questions you
may have yeah thank you very much indeed
so um I'm going to have to declare
another um
another um registrable interest because
pensions have been mentioned and I sit
on the ess6 lgps pension strategy board
and the investment steering
committee um uh and I understand the
settlement is due on Christmas Eve which
is a nice bonus for uh over the
Christmas period a little bit for that
well that's the DAT I was advised um so
members um well just by way over a
change councelor
fluka no there's nobody else indicating
I was um really going to ask a question
about the optim optimistic view of the
Chief Financial Officer with regards to
a million pounds worth of investment
income in 2425 CH I asked that question
cuz the chief economists to the bank of
England reported through my account
that's price waterhous today that they
are expecting to see uh a tail off in uh
the the base rate in the next next 18
months quite a significant one although
I think looking at the the the Autumn
statement yesterday um it looked very
inflationary to me so I I would I think
I'm asking the question because I'm very
very cautious about that million pound
sitting in in there and of course that
million pound has a huge effect on our
bottom line if it's not achieved
likewise in the following two years so
chairman I I I've really do think that
it would be nice to have some
information around why the1 is confident
that that figure could be delivered um
chairman with regards repairs and
renewals um there's quite a lot of money
in
6.1 um and I'm I'm very sort it it
something came up at one of the working
groups other day chairman about the
whole principle of tendering for a
project and understanding what it's
going to cost and there's absolutely
nothing for anybody there's nothing to
stop this Council going to a contractor
or contractors and asking how much
deliver this project and would they like
to Tender in the future there's nothing
in the Comm there's absolutely nothing
in our rules that prohibits that but I I
just thought West molden Community
Center um chairman I know you love to
jump in and and and declare an interest
but i't got one in that well you know
chairman I was just going to say to you
I'm I'm a queen Scout which now makes me
feel quite old cuz we got a king now uh
there may be others looking to my left
but chairman that that figure concerns
me because it does seem a little bit low
for what needs to be done there and
likewise I think the the the recovering
but we we'll deal with that later but
I'm I'm I I just really do need to
understand the thinking behind a million
pounds worth of investment income I'm
sure we can get an answer for that
thanks Council fluka um yeah so as we
said in the previous report the current
budget for um investment income is
£750,000 and we are forecasting to
overachieve that by £500,000
um this year um
so the um target for next year is
actually a reduction on what we expect
to achieve this year and that does
reflect the fact that we are expecting
interest rates to gradually come down
the interest rate forecasts that we've
used are based on our expert treasury
management advisor forecast in terms of
the interest rates but obviously we will
take um under consideration any changes
um in those forecasts as we come to set
the budgets finally um but in addition
to the interest rates um it obviously
impacted by the level of cash balances
that the council holds as well so we
have that is our best um estimate um at
this moment um and while I don't want to
be overly optimistic um I suppose it's
in uh members should note that if we are
too pessimistic that does mean that we
then need to obviously find savings um
elsewhere in the council so I think it
is um prudent to take the right view in
terms of of of not being overly
pessimistic um but obviously taking the
best advice to make sure that we've got
an accurate estimate of what we expect
to to
achieve um in terms of the West molden
Community Center um I believe that's
based on um sort of quotes or estimates
from our internal offices um I don't
know if any um officers want to comment
on on that specifically but if not I
will um take that away but I believe
that that that that figure has been
arrived at um with the appropriate due
diligence thank you m um yeah okay thank
you Mr Bas thank you chair even members
um sorry just to reassure those
estimates are based on uh colleagues
understanding of of the assets um
current cost of materials inflation
pressures and his his quite extensive
now experience in the asset so uh we're
very confident that's an estimate we can
deliver the project within thank you
chairman okay thank you uh Council f and
then councel
driver
res 24,000 yeah Mich um 4.2 with respect
to the Contra contribution from reserves
for the pension fund deficit says
£240,000 I mean are we expecting I know
that we we're sort of running that debt
down but are we expecting the
contribution to for that that low
really because it was a million pound
over 3 years now we're talking 240,000
been three
years um my account fit it thank you um
so yeah as you're aware we um have a
triangual pension valuation um and as
part of that we are required to make a
contribution to the historic pension
deficit um we have a reserve set aside
which we make a contribution to each
year to then finance that over a
three-year period um and the forast um
is based on the current level of our
reserve and our expected draw down on
that over the next 3 years so that is is
our best estimate at this stage but as I
say we monitor that um at each threeyear
period to make sure that that's um
appropriate thank you councelor driver
uh thank you chair um uh two questions
uh one is going from a million pound to
20,000 so uh on page
50 uh
5.1 under the table two gross and
unavoidable pressures the the it's a
small point but recycling bags uh is
just interesting that in you know it's
going up uh 20,000 so that's
33% uh in in one year and then another
33% in the following year that seems an
avoidable pressure as opposed to
unavoidable pressure that seem very
large I I'll just put that out there the
second point and I just a clarification
really and that is whether actually
what's being presented here uh builds in
any of the say potential savings that we
might be looking at later on or whether
this is the position before we look at
any savings that we might be looking at
later on just to clarify that position
thank you yeah thank you councelor if I
answer your first sorry your last Point
first um I apologize if I didn't make
that clear in my introduction but yeah
as I said um that does not include the
impact of any savings proposals so we
have not assumed that at this stage so
this is before before that um terms of
the recycling bags um again that's based
on our best estimate of known volume so
obviously as recycling goes up and as
the number of households in the district
goes up um that will increase in terms
of volume but also the price of those
bags is um driven by oil prices
essentially because of the cost of
plastic um and again with inflationary
pressures that's kind of an unavoidable
cost just stop on sorry sorry just that
does in a very large PR either there's a
huge amount of extra building going on
across the district which you're not
aware of or the cost of plastic bags is
really rocketing I believe it is
primarily the inflation that's causing
the pressure thank you all right thank
you okay
members we have two recommendations the
assumptions underpinning the
mtfs uh are reviewed and the projected
impact on the general fund balance table
five is
noted do I please show happy thank you
very much indeed that's carried
okay uh item 10 fees and charges
schedule
20242 who's taking us through this
that's me
oh I'll give someone else a minute
here okay thank you committee um so the
purpose of this report is to review the
proposed um fees and charges for
2425 um and make recommendation to
council for those that are forecast to
generate greater than £2,000 um for each
individual line and to note that um for
any that are forecast to achieve less
than 2,000s um that they are reviewed um
and set by myself under the delegated
powers so the proposed fees and charges
for 2425 are detailed in appendix a um
and are based on the fees and charges
policy report agreed by this committee
um on the 21st of September however it
should be noted that that policy um has
yet to go to council and is therefore
subject to council ratification at the
meeting on the 29th uh of
November um there is also a second
appendix which is set out at appendix B
which summarizes the changes which are
proposed I would like to just
specifically draw members attention to
paragraph 3.4 which notes the warid fees
um in terms of the policy which was
considered by this cons by this
Committee in September um there was an
oversight um in terms of the warid fees
um because um at Council in February
there was an agreement to um um continue
to apply 50% discount on those fees for
a further three years um and that was
not reflected in the policy however
there will be um a correction to that
that's brought forward to C IL at the
next meeting before that policy is
agreed um and there is no intention um
as I believe subject to any any Council
decision um to to amend amend that
policy so that was just an oversight and
and will be
corrected um so in terms of the rest of
the fees and charges um in the majority
of cases we are proposing to increase
those by inflation which is the
council's policy um and that rate is 7
.4% based on the Consumer Price Index as
at August
2023 there are some charges which are
recommended for an above inflation
increase and they include um recycling
refuges and green waste collection and
the objective of that is to try and
achieve full cost recovery um which this
committee um will note is um again the
policy of the
council um car parking charges proposed
are as per the reports um again
considered in September with a further
proposed increase to evenings Sundays
and bank
holidays in terms of planning
pre-application fees um we are proposing
to increase those in line with the
statutory planning fle planning fee
increases which are proposed by central
government and that again will enable us
to increase our cost recovery on those
um
Services um there's a couple of other
items which are proposed to be raised um
by above inflation which are set out in
the report which are to act as a
deterrent um for um uh stray dogs and um
for antisocial
Behavior there is a few lines which I
propose not to be increased and again
they're detailed within the report um
and there are two new charges which are
proposed um license variation and
license revisit to rescore um and they
are um proposed to be introduced to
reflect the cost of carrying out those
services so if all of the fees and
charges are agreed as set out in
appendix a the forecast is that that
would help the council achieve an
additional three just over £300,000
income um next year compared to
2324 um but just to again reiterate that
that will only help the council to um
recover its costs um we are not we are
not um statutorily allowed to make to
profit on our services so so none of
those fees um reflect any profit
making um I think I will probably leave
it there and take any questions that
councilors may have thank you yeah uh
and I will we are not revisiting each
individual fees and charge I can assure
you of that so we've already been there
councelor
driver uh this yes this just reflects or
or or relates to appendix a on H page 59
it's just interesting to note that
whereas in most cases inflation has been
applied and in other cases you outlined
as far as gambling is concerned there is
no change in any
gambling charges and that was just an
interesting that we've made a decision
not to change any of those I think I
think those are set by Statute in in
actual fact I believe so part your
gambling act so I don't think we have
leeway on that councelor dri I stand to
be corrected but as I understand thank
you the uh the gambling laws those are
fixed fees yeah yeah they are thank you
um yes gambling is statutory I've had
that pinged through on my chat councelor
lagen I know you want to talk about the
warid fees that are not for long thank
you chair that's very good of you sir
thank you just probably my stat you
three minutes and I'll use it well um
first I want to thank um Mr porus for
his help because I raised the issue of
the um uh confusion in the report that
came through which Miss Lucas has
identified to this committee that the
agreement was for the council to give
the barges at that that rate of what is
24883 and to have for three years the
agreement was there was an inflation
increase which was rather High last year
um but that was what was agreed and that
was what was applied so that was fair um
so I just want to make sure that members
old and new know that that was what was
agreed um and assure the members of the
public and those other barge operators
because if we had applied the the
position as we had have intended to
apply we probably would have put them
out of business um and the key thing is
there that also in the report that was
levied to Council on the 21st of
September which actually had um some
information on the on the um fees and
charges on appendix one where it talked
about existing concessions and it set um
it said set the fees to compete with
alternative birthing facilities on the
East Coast members there are none so we
had to decide on what what fees we be
provided just to birth at the key and
and I'm grateful for this committee to
make sure that that actually is is Levy
to council and that is clearly
identified in any minutes because if you
agree this policy as is you're agreeing
the increase which is in the
documentation which is actually
43% so I think that's got to be very
very clearly identified that that was
what was agreed so if you look at the
the
document and it is you're agreeing the
policy and principle and I don't want to
go through the line because I've been
clearly um instructed that's not we're
here to do if you agree on this it goes
from um page 67 from
£248 uh to next year to £
4,139 where it should be in line with
inflation which will probably be about 7
and half% so 7 half% compounded on top
of £ 2,48 is what should be
going so just need Clarity that the
committee accepts that and that's what
we'll be
going um Council has already agreed at
Council fluk yeah correct yeah as you
will recall at at full Council we
extended the 50% discount and as you'd
appreciate Council lag and we full
Council will have to go back and amend
these when it's presented at full
Council next week lovely so there won't
be any amendments to full Council next
week because we've already careful
Council already agreed
it that item chair no but it will it
will amend this report for Council sorry
if I may just clarify sorry there was
two separate reports so there was the
policy report which was previously
agreed which um did not reflect the um
decision at Council to Discount the
wolid fees um which was previously
agreed in February so that that um that
report has already been referred into
Council so that is the report that will
need to be corrected when it is
considered um next week however this
report is the detailed fees and charges
schedule um and this report does not
actually require amending or correcting
um because the actual fee levels
themselves are not um to be changed it
is the policy of applying the discount
so the underlying fee will be set as
normal um the the uh decision by Council
to then apply the 50% discount will be
reflected in the policy document which
is the report that which will need
amending next week just for clarity so
the 4,139 will drop down to
2,000 whatever it actually is plus
whatever rate of inflation comes upon
that in in terms of what's build yes but
the actual headline fee on the the fees
and charges schedule will not change um
but it's the policy to then apply a
discount to that but the the underlying
fee level will not will not change on
the schedule but there will be a policy
of then applying that to the bills the
discount but that discount will not is
not to be phased out because that's not
what was disc years years it wasn't 20%
next year 20% the year after and 10% the
year after because that will all of the
discount and they will be paying through
the nose like a wounded ball so that's
my key that's my key concern because
that's where Council agreed in February
that it should have 50% discount over a
three-year period so that's what
y thank you thank you CH I just got one
other question and it's nothing to do
with bar as you'll be glad to know but
by the passion that we have um we need
to make sure we look after these assets
there's an awful lot of um price on
application uh in the in the detail so I
was just wondering um is that something
that is I know not to be discussed now
because you're going to agree it but
it's just something I've noted that
awful lot of what sorry I price on
application on on on the detailed lines
on the schedules so you you can't agree
something when you don't know what the
price is yeah please so um I think on
those um lines it's where we cannot give
um an accurate um figure because um it
will depend on for example um I'm just
looking at the one about electricity
Supply and the usage of that so um as we
said our policy is to recover all of our
um costs so in the case of you know a
particular event or something where we
needed to recover our cost it would not
be possible to determine in advance
exactly what that charge would be so
that's where we would have to provide um
a price on application right thank you
members so uh You' had the detailed fees
and charges
schedule oh sorry councelor I think you
were first councelor
stamp do thank you J just for clarity
3.4 is going to be removed then is
it of the report before it goes to
council which is what it says the wage
fees or is it staying cuz I'm actually
confused so is it going to to change
from the previous
um resolution um as as I sorry through
you I know you
explained yeah so the this report um as
I say needs to be um does not reflect
the decision that was made so we can we
can remove that paragraph So it's
absolutely clear but the the decision of
this committee is to refer the actual
schedule to council so the schedule
itself does not need amending but I I
accept that the this report gives an um
is not an accurate reflection of the the
decision that was made in February thank
you chair that's what I wanted
confirmation counc
fluka um I'm thinking about getting in
my super yach and buying a T's barge uh
it'd be a lot cheaper to keep it on the
river um chairman can we just go to page
uh
61 um chairman the officers I mean I are
these proposals from officers or is this
the policy no these are these result
from the policies set by this committee
oh right okay well
chairman it's always interesting
settling the policy when you don't have
the information but with regards to page
61 and recycling in particular green
beans um chairman it's the intent of the
policy of this committee members
officers to increase the green bean fee
from 56
to70 um my concern is that at the waste
working group recently um it was
established that that service provides
uh a surplus I think of £
377,000 per anom um chairman and I
really do think the the public should be
made aware of that I suspect there
should be some costs that are offloaded
against that but at the at the waste
contract working group um there wasn't
much forthcoming at all and I think
that's going to be a very bitter pill
for the for our residents to swall
swallow and then moving on chairman to
Refuge collection um I just wondered
these increases for bulky waste they do
seem to be incredibly low be in mind how
much a 6m skip or 7 met skip costs to
hire and bearing in mind that you can
put 10 to 12 items maximum for 180 that
does sound like good um that sounds like
good value for the customer likewise uh
the um Refuge disposal abandoned
vehicles I'm not sure how many of these
things we actually get involved with
chairman but again that looks from my
own experience very inexpensive or or
cheap as Mr stamp just said um and and
CH moving on to off street parking I
mean this is one that um we were on
appendix a page 64 and in particularly
Sunday all day and bank holidays um if
I've read this right check The Proposal
from officers the policy of this
committee or perhaps even members um is
suggesting increasing this to £190 that
sounds like incredibly good value on a
on a bank holiday to use our car Parks
chairman we're talking about closing
gaps um we've got this old Legacy gap
which goes back somewh that really does
not sound right to me German that fee
for all day parking um chairman he
key um on page 65 this is this is the
season ticket for car parking um I think
we all know there's huge issues down
there with parking at the moment
chairman I know this isn't the
appropriate place to mention it but I
will uh it's not police there's a lot of
cars left down there regularly without
any tickets on or or parking permits on
chairman and and I think we need to make
sure that these these permits shouldn't
be available to everybody there should
be some way of controlling who gets them
and I'm not sure there is
and uh and the Town Center residential
car parks on page 65 again a resident
season ticket I know it's only from 5:
to 10 P 5:00 p.m. to 10 p.m. 5:00 p.m.
to 10: p.m. uh during the week and all
day on Sunday but I think uh an the cost
of the the annual ticket at £88 doeses
seem disproportionately low with regards
to to other costs chairman um I did pick
up on this price on application and I I
I understand there's a reason why
there's no figures in there but I think
some of these can be populated and I
think it's important to see what that
population looks like chairman um and
then moving on to uh page 67 chairman um
near the top Su Summit talks about uh a
season ticket Sports pitch use parking
season ticket per team so is this
156 chairman for 11 players four
substitutes the manager and the ball boy
or is this just or is this just one
ticket I I really don't understand that
chairman uh and the well Council speaker
I did say we weren't going to go through
these line by line you will have noted
Council fluka that the the the subject
of the green bin charge is the subject
of a of an item in PNC later so I don't
propose to to go no councelor F we have
debate of for Council and because this
is this is really important this is our
residents money again you know I think
sometimes the
fact green bin is to be discussed later
under private and confidential you will
be aware that the the car parking
charges are recommended by the car park
working group which is a working group
of members and the members sat down
together and decided that the the car
parking charges so unless you're going
to challenge the the the the
deliberations of the car park working
group which well okay then that's your
prerogative but that has been that has
been councelor fluka that has been a
resolution of that working group
councelor driver it's just an
observation um that Council Fluker is
particularly concerned about car parking
charges in molden which I understand and
I think a lot of us are concerned about
car parking charges however it is the
only area in the district that charges
for car parking so actually uh I
understand the concern that you have
have councelor Fluker over for car
parking charges but I think it goes
wider than just molden thank you
councelor thank you councelor driver so
I'm going to go back to the
recommendation go councilor white sorry
you're on my peripheral vision sorry
yeah I've just got one um query with the
green bins um have we actually cleared
the backlog cuz I know there's residents
in my ward can't actually get a green
bin because it's over subscribed so has
that been addressed it's it it's not
part of the fees and charges councelor
white We're No we're discussing fees and
charges not the availability of green
bins so members um I'm sure you can get
an answer to that question direct from
the the officer it's this you know this
this agenda item is fees and charges so
re thank you this uh so members do we
agree this schedule of fees and charges
those in favor please show those in
favor please
show one two three four
seven those
against reced of course councelor
because I want the residents know that
I'm not in favor of taking all this
additional money from them and I'm just
going to look on YouTube and see how
many are actually
watching of course thank you that's
carried
recomendation it is a recommendation to
Council of course so you have a second
go Council fluka um that you suddenly
realize how the governance this work
okay um Capital uh next agenda item item
11 Capital bids who's taking us through
this another
one
okay thank you thank you um so um item
11 Capital bids
2425 um the purpose of this report is to
consider the capitalle projects that
have been put forward by officers prior
to their approval of the 2425 budget and
the updated
mtfs um the recommendation is that the
committee reviews the bids um in order
to inform the proposed Capital program
which will be taken back to this
Committee in January um before being
taken to council for approval in um
February
2024 so section three of the report um
at table one sets out the bids that have
been received from officers and the
detail behind those individual projects
can be found at appendix
a the projects have been categorized by
officers into three main groups um
either essential Works which are um
likely to result in
in health and safety implications where
they not to proceed um or which would
have a fundamental impact on service
provision um the second category is
service failure so these relate to
operational assets that require funding
to ensure their continued
reliability and the third category is
invest to save so capital investment in
these projects um is expected to reduce
Revenue expenditure in the long run um
in relation to that asset on an ongoing
basis so members will note that the
total of the capital bids received for
this year um is just over £500,000 um
and I would just draw members attention
to paragraph 3.4 which notes that the
council had 1.6 million of capital um
Reserves at the start of this financial
year um however it was agreed to use 0.6
million of those um in this financial
year so there is1 million um to support
the future program for next year and
Beyond um so it should be noted that in
the absence of any new sizable Capital
receipts from disposal dis osal of
assets that the council would be likely
to use up its capital reserves within
the next few years um and in that case
it would require um borrowing to finance
any future capital
expenditure um so again happy to take
any individual questions that you may
have councelor white first right thank
you Mr chairman um I have to say I've
got these bids here but I'm really
disappointed with the actual reports
because we haven't got into the finances
now I've always supported all of the
funding for all of of the Leisure
centers every single time it's come up
I've supported them but here we go we've
got denji 100 um wanting to extend the
gym um can you tell me what profit um it
makes for molden District Council uh as
opposed to how much we have to pay for
the upkeep of the denji 100 and why this
is uh comes out of molden District
council's purse because uh unless we're
making a profit to see a return on that
80,000 I can't see that that's
relevant um so while you get those
figures I'll be interested to hear them
um the promar
that wasn't even built very long ago
again what's the profit margin on it is
it financially viable um I say I
supported that I supported the original
funding to build it when we first built
it but the fact need 85,000 it's not
even that old um is a little bit
worrying and and we need to now we're in
the times that we're in we need to think
okay so what are we getting back from
these and again I've always supported
all the play areas but there comes a
point where we are now that we have to
um look with where where we are um the
pathways at longfields require full
tarmac um is there any way that anybody
else can pick up on this um you know
developers and or
um uh collections or something that's
local um so yeah and then we come to the
cutting machines and the John Deere
Gator vehicle replacement that's
65,000 this this ties in I've been
asking for about the last 10 years for a
full service review of all of the grass
cutting and grounds maintenance because
I've always said that we could I think
we could do it cheaper with um
contractors um than we can with in-house
staff and so we're looking at 65,000
here for two machines um and I can tell
you for 65,000 you get an awful lot of
Contracting work done with grass cutting
um so again I think those should be put
off and we should get a full report as
I've been asking for about the last
decade probably um for these reports to
be done so again I'm not not anti them
being done but there has to be a cost
benefit not just that we'd like them you
know in the times that we're in we can't
just say oh yeah another 100,000 here
and
there so that's my questions okay thank
you Mr Luc is going to go first and then
Mr butcher thank you thank you Council
white for your comments um just as a
more General point I suppose in terms of
the capital investment that's required
by the council as you aware the council
um holds a number of assets which are
for the wider um public goods and for
Service delivery for the council um
obviously Financial considerations are
one part of of the consideration of um
the operation of those assets but it's
not the only um consideration because
there is the wider um public good that
we need to consider um so I in in
respect of your comments around the
Leisure centers and the parks for
example um yeah that they are assets
that the council currently holds and is
not planning to divest itself of I and
in that respect we have to to keep them
up to a certain minimum standard of um
operation um and the investment um that
set out in the report would would enable
us to do that um in terms of the Leisure
centers particularly um I think um Mr
Butch might come in in a sec um but as
you'll be aware we are currently out to
procurement on our Leisure Services more
generally um and um the financial
considerations um of the operation of
the Leisure centers will be um one of
the key considerations in terms of who
who we award that that contracts to in
the future so um yeah Mr butcher wants
to add that
point yes thanks councelor white yeah I
think um the dingi 100 the um uh the
site is shared with the burnam mon CR
Sport Club where they do the rugby uh
cricket and croquet the Rugby Club are
actually expanding their footprint uh to
build new changing rooms so the council
will be getting back in uh uh some of
its um some of the footprint on the
building um but that will be the old
changing rooms that are used by the
Rugby Club so the £80,000 investment
would then be used to uh expand the gym
and perhaps put in a small Studio which
in turn will create more more revenue
and more income uh at that
location no not yet Mr
Holmes thank you chairman I think just
to strengthen um what1 officer said this
evening so there are a number of arets
um prade Park the item is now plus 24
years old um subject to some structural
movement um sits on the edge of the Bank
by the the lake we have to maintain it
in its current location it for a purpose
of containing all the plant room and the
pumps for the uh for the park and and
the lake itself so these items are are
coming forward to you tonight as as
cyclical um some end of life um and I
think as as as explained those assets
are there and we need to maintain them
to a suitable standard um I think it
might be useful to invite Mr Harwood
white to say a couple of words on the
par team um I would I think I'll invite
him just to comment on the work he's
doing with the parks team itself um but
I would like to say also looking options
around shared services talking to other
local authorities to get best value um
from the service but I'll ask Mr har
white to comment
please thank you chair um the we are
reviewing uh as part of normal process
the operation of the parch Open Spaces
Team part of that is culminated in
report this evening on the PNC um regard
one part of the service uh that work
will continue uh we'll look at those
options going forward um but uh we'll
bring it back to council appropriate
time at the moment we focused on a
particular area of that service which
we'll be debating on the PNC later thank
you chair come back once canoun thank
you Mr yeah but if I go back to the DJI
100 you're saying it's an asset that we
have to maintain I accept that we're
talking about extending it we rent this
or try and rent it to esset County
Council and they make a profit on it
they're running a business on it no we
don't well they they're supposed to be
it goes to Essex Place Services I
thought sorry one of the essics come
anyway whoever rents it it's a business
they make a profit on it it's not a
charity so if they want to make a profit
they need to invest and if we're out to
procurement surely wait and see if
anybody takes it on wait and see what
benefit there's going to be more to more
residents first then stump up the 80
odd, thousand to put the money in we we
we're putting the money in before we
even know if there's going to be any
return okay as let Mr but do you want to
come out Mr butcher yeah thanks uh
thanks chair yes um absolutely it will
be part of the procurement process but
the um the the Rugby Club intending to
start their Works um in the in the close
season next year and we don't want to be
in a position where we have a uh
facility that that's sitting there empty
that the reason the DJI is a cost to us
is because the size of it is prohibitive
in in how much income it can generate
and and um members of the Leisure
contract working group uh attended a
site visit there and and this was
explained uh to them quite quite
thoroughly in in detail and I think the
opportunity there to expand the gym and
or bring in a new studio we'll only uh
increase the opportunity
there thank you you guarantee we're
going to get an income thank right
councelor F yeah same microphone please
I think this may be Mis misclassified
because I wouldn't be as essential
because it really is making use of space
that will become available should the
Rugby Club take the um um um far way but
the problem is in terms we probably will
have to do something at a point of time
but the way I understand things at the
moment is that if we're at for contract
procurement then it's highly unlikely
that police Leisure will make an
investment in the next year with to in
in terms of putting in more gym
equipment until they know whether or not
they' actually got the contract so I
would say that potentially this work
would be premature and what we'd end up
with just an amount of space that's
empty until we've decided upon which
vendor is going to take that contract
forward and it might well be that as
part of that contract tendering process
that we would say well fine we've got
these gyms you do what you want with
them and avoid the cost completely so
I'm not sure on this one to be honest
okay has anybody got any reply to
Council of f i mean it's obviously an
opinion I mean it is an invest to save
I'm guessing isn't it that's the point
of that absolutely it's an invest to
save to hope uh to to bring more
customers like I say the space there um
you know councilor ftic is is
prohibitive and they can't actually get
any more members because the gym is so
so small I think the um the opportunity
this presents to us is um well an
investment at the facility that will
increase membership numbers and actually
uh improve the service down at um down
at Burmont Crouch but as part of the
procurement we are looking at a range of
options for capital investment for uh
the biders to come in with and that will
be done through the procurement process
so uh yeah nothing further okay thank
you councelor Lagan just just quickly
thank you chair I hear what Mr holes
said about the amphitheater because it's
raised a few eyebrows as well and it is
in a starting to get into a little bit
of a state of disrepair but I want
members to remember what this was for
this is an Amphitheater I remember many
years ago when I lived in Australia
coming back and seeing A Midsummer
Night's Dream in there as an event so
there's an opportunity there for
commercial opportunities for us to look
at it I would be very very concerned if
we RI the Wings off CU they're the seats
they're not steps so it's not a health
and safety issue with with regard to
that we could easily put concrete steps
around either side so that people can
access the seats and then we could look
like maximizing that asset to to be what
it is if we start taking it away we're
going to get we've took away the lake
we've took away the amphitheater we're
giving away all the things that we said
we would keep and reward the people so I
think the health and safety aspects are
definitely there but I agree with
councelor white I think that this should
be deferred uh with a little bit more
detail and then maybe linked into the
commercial opportunity chairman I'm
looking to my colleagues but I don't
believe this is to remove anything I
think it's actually to repair and
strengthen the existing structure as it
stands at the moment perhaps Mr I white
could comment thank you chair um so to
clarify um we would be looking at um at
certain strengthening improving and
making safe parts that would be um those
it's difficult to describe without
images um
removing those those lower steps and
making them safe the amphitheater is as
a structure would still exist it would
still be that a structure there we would
have to amend what's described in the
report as the wings so those initial
steps on left and right hand side you
would still have an Ampitheater you
still have um an asset there we just
slightly modify those end Wings to make
them safe and make some repairs but you
also to have the asset there to enjoy
just to for clarity thank you chair but
it actually says in the report it says
it says the project was see is
decommission of the current Wing steps
there's not not steps the wings are not
steps there're seats on there there's no
seats when you go up I went down this
morning at 10 5 to a look at it another
look at it just to clarify myself so
maybe the detail in the report probably
need to be a little bit sharper um so
you you can confirm that those that will
still will still have an Amphitheater
and there would still be Provisions for
seating where the pump house is I can
confirm that chairman yes thank you
councelor Langan this is this is
undoubtedly an asset and I would hope
that when we're starting to look at
events we're going to you know sweat
this asset and use it use it for events
no counselor why I've got counselor
stamp and then counselor fluka yeah
thank you um I hope when it is repaired
it looks as good as the burn and um key
we've actually got it repaired the first
time in since God knows how long yeah
took a long time to do that was ESS
County Council my question is
Remembrance Avenue could you tell me how
long the road surface repair is where
does it start and where's it and there
is a reason for me asking for the detail
here because there is a Ransom strip is
my understanding no there was a ransom
strip it away yeah so I'd like to know
if you can chair let tell me where the
resurfacing where it actually follows CU
it does it can I just interrupt can I
just interrupt I'm sorry Council Fluker
I heard you say this lot gave it away
could you yes chairman that a reference
to the full Council of course I can um
you remember that there was a section1
officer Director of Finance uh Missing
and when when they B forward the
development on the old seafast site um
which was just for the benefit of
everybody this was the um Fisheries site
the old fishery I'm fully aware I'm
clarifying what I said in the same way
as you give me the opportunity to do so
so what happened was chairman the um the
proposal came forward to build half a
dozen executive houses on that site
chairman and we all knew that there was
a r strip there and the ransom strip was
originally valued at a quar a million
quid because correct me if I'm wrong but
it's a grampian agreement and what
happened chairman was that the agreement
evaporated away and this slot the
council just let it go and they ended up
building six houses can you can you when
you say this lot can you say the council
because I don't the counil everybody
people people of southminster and and
and
there might be there might be three
people in southminster looking at
YouTube because currently there's 11
watching and which includes seven
officers and myself so there three in
South Miner we gave we coun thank you
coun clarifying it I've clarified it we
gave it we gave thank you could somebody
answer councelor stamp's question thank
you CH thank you chair I think the
question related to um remember Avenue
and the question was around the size of
the area yes uh the report sets out uh
260 square m
surface that it's it's on the image it
shows edged in white on the image on
page page 100 thank you
chair right Council of LCA one last
comment uh well chairman I I want to
comment on a couple of these and and
I'll be as brief as I possibly can chman
I I can't see any reason in spending any
money on the D g00 Sports Center until
we understand what the new contract
looks like because my understanding it
might be um that that might be annexed
away from the main contracts and then
we'd have to try and fund somebody else
chairman so spending money on it
chairman i' i' I'd also ask uh officers
to look at the the U the planning
application made by buron Sports Club my
understanding is is that they agreed to
pay for some car parking spaces chairman
and it would be a shame if they've
agreed to do that and then we pick up
the bill because that's clearly not what
was what was agreed I think at the
planning application and chairman the
one on here that that um concerns me
enormously and I don't think anyone's
spoken to it and apologies I think it's
counselor Thompson's Ward um and this is
the garages at Gold hanger although that
might be councelor um there's something
in here which is there's a massive risk
in this chairman and it talks about
compulsory purchase uh or of one of
these garages was was the Freeholder was
sold I I'm not quite sure how that
happened but one of the one of the
garages was sold chairman and we're
talking about a compulsory uh order I
mean I one presumes that this site is is
right for development which then brings
us into a gramping agreement chairman
and I think we really need to understand
uh the true cost of this if there's a
compulsory uh purchase order involved in
it and the other thing chairman is
there's the mention of the a word but it
doesn't mention what type of a it is and
chairman if this is the wrong type of
asbestos you could be talking about
£100,000 20,000 per garage to clear this
and yet I think we've got a figure a
figure in here £35,000 which includes
the clearing of the asbestos the
clearing of the site and also dealing
with a compulsory purch compulsory
purchase agreement £335,000 probably
won't even pay the legal fees on the
compulsory purchase thank you councel so
I wonder if we can have some more
information on that sure I'm sure we can
and I think it's you know I think when
these things come forward I think that
it's very important to have them
properly costing thank
you please do yeah thank you thanks
Council fer um just in relation to
compulsory purchase um I don't believe
that the the the costs of that are um
what's reflected in the report the the
the bid is to make the site safe um and
then any future decision about what is
done with that site and um any
compulsory purchase would would be
separate to that so just to clarify on
that particular Point um I will let
other officers come back in terms of the
detail of the other proposals thank you
um Mr Hood white you want to come
back chair that actually another point
but um please yeah yeah whatever thank
you through you chair I just ask I could
come back on the amphitheater point if I
may um just to offer chairman if it
helps members um if it was helpful I'd
be happy to share when we have them um
some drawings and images of the
proposals for the amphitheater perhaps
of the member work the asset member work
group and Ward members at the
appropriate time that's helpful chair
just to
ratio
okay right thank you
members members the recommendation
the recommendation is that you review
the capital bids in appendix
a
um and to recommend the capital program
to strategy and resources in January
24 to be approved by Council in February
24 there was talk of deferring with
pushing back and pushing back and unless
we agree this to this report tonight
we're not going to have enough time I
don't think to deliver these
projects but um
so I'm sorry councilor
fluka I don't think you've made a I'm
not sure if your proposal is not being
seconded but I haven't asked it to be
seconded yet but I'll dive in quickly
then because I would propose chairman
that that these go forward to council to
be decided upon but they are anyway
council with the exception with the
exception of the denji 100 um project uh
it's good to see the burnam members
agreeing with me um chairman which
should really go back and be considered
in relation to the ongoing so is that a
proposal it is a propos put these for
just a moment sorry guess is that a
proposal to move them forward with the
exception of the denji 100 and is that
seconded counc bound councelor white did
you I'd also like to propose that 12 and
13 are removed until the entire service
for the ground maintenance is reviewed
I've been asking for The Last 5 Years
because we don't know no we need to get
councelor sorry Mr Holmes wants to
comment chairman i' have some difficulty
with that because we only ask these isms
of equipment to replace when we
literally worn everything else out and
they've still got to provide a service
even if you decide later to do something
so I can't see how we con contain can
maintain a service with not the right
equipment okay thank you so we have uh
um a proposal in the name Council of
Luca secondly by Council of bound to
recommend these go through with the
exception of the denji 100 those in
favor of councelor fluker's
prop you're shaking your head councelor
can I make an amendment no no we've got
we've got a proposal on the table well
I'd like to voice that I'd like to make
Amendment to the proposal right Council
of w stamp I would like to say um I'll
support the proposal as long as the
80,000 isn't then lost and put somewhere
else to another project in M we can't do
that
Council it then because because it's
being removed from the capital program
at council at fluker's request that is
the proposal chairman thank you chairman
but I'm going to withdraw my proposal
and amend it to include that so chairman
everything goes forward apart from that
the 880,000 is Wing Fen and the for the
future and that the whole thing is then
pushed back to the corporate projects
board you could just Recon take that
away and reconsider it bring it back to
SNR in January want the
work right okay how about this councelor
fluka that we agree the other items and
we remove that and we bring that item
alone back to strategy and resources in
January chairman to help you finish this
meeting by 10 o' I'll agree thank you
very much indeed so we have that
proposal Council bound you happy to
second that so this so the proposal is
to agree all capital bids with the
exception of the denji 100 which will be
brought back to count to SNR in January
please those in favor please
show that's uh pretty much everybody so
that is carried thank you very much
members
okay uh so item eight exclusion of the
press and public that under section 100a
of the Local Government Act 1972 the
public be excluded from the meeting for
the following items of business on the
grounds that they involve the likely
disclosure of exempt information as
defined in paragraph 3 of set part one
of schedule 12a to the ACT and this
satisfies the public interest test I so
move do I have a seconder thank you very
much all in
favor thank you very much if you can let
us